after months of delays spacex received
word from regulators about the fate of
its starbase launch site it's a pretty
big deal for the company and the faa
basically you know gave the company the
green light to move forward on monday
the faa released its final environmental
assessment of the company's south texas
location the assessment found that
continued launches at the bogochica site
would not significantly affect the
quality of the human environment it was
a big hurdle i mean it created
a fair amount of i guess you call it
regulatory uncertainty it means that
spacex has a pathway forward to start
the kind of testing to show that this
gigantic rocket really can work
the agency's assessment also found that
before it can start orbital launches
spacex must carry out more than 75
actions to mitigate the effects of the
launches on the surrounding area and
environment these actions range from
noise restrictions to monitoring the
lighting at the launch site to preparing
a report on historic events that took
place in the area during the
mexican-american war and the civil war
so what does this assessment mean for
spacex and the starship program going
forward
moreover what does it mean for nasa's
plan to get the us back to the moon by
2025
last year spacex ceo elon musk announced
that he was creating a new city called
star base at boca chica village an
unincorporated community of about 30
homes located next to the southernmost
beach in texas
spacex originally planned to use the
site for launches of its falcon 9 and
falcon heavy rockets but later it
decided to use starbase to develop its
much larger starship spacecraft
spacex has been conducting sub-orbital
starship launches at boca chica since
2019
but for the spaceship's development to
continue the faa requires additional
permitting starship is the the biggest
and most powerful rocket system spacex
has ever developed it's meant for some
of the companies most ambitious deep
space missions
although many in the state welcome the
increased investment and jobs some in
south texas are concerned that spacex's
expansion will come at a steep price to
the environment one of the major
concerns is that the faa hasn't done
enough analysis of what the effects
of operating starship you know from this
location would be
bokeh chica sits at the edge of a
national wildlife refuge but since
spacex began expanding its operations in
2019
some conservationists worry that the
eventual environmental impact will be
devastating
the faa's final environmental assessment
of the boko chica site was expected last
year
however the agency pushed back the
deadline five times saying spacex made
changes to its application that required
additional analysis one of the big
reasons that this has been delayed
multiple times is because
the faa said almost 20 000 people have
weighed in on this and provided public
comment you know for against and they
had to to go through those
the breadth of submissions range from
opposition by a wildlife biologist to
support from an engineer
others were submitted on behalf of
groups and many were pages long
the completion of the assessment does
not guarantee that the faa will issue
spacex a launch license spacex's
application must also meet faa safety
risk and financial requirements spacex
expects the first orbital launch of its
starship spacecraft to take place later
this year
starship is designed for voyages to the
moon and mars and nasa selected starship
to return humans to the moon in 2025.
they can't start launching immediately
it's it's not
quite that simple the company also has
to
make sure it's
you know complying with all of these
these actions
so they still have some some steps to go
before
they start launching spacex did not
respond to multiple requests for comment
but shortly after the faa's decision the
company did tweet that starship was one
step closer to its first orbital flight